question of the last day of this very
exciting Workshop it's my great pleasure
to introduce Franklin Hollander or Frank
Daniel as we would say
um Frank is from Leiden and he will be
talking about large deviation principles
for the spectral radius of inhomogeneous
uh eritreaning random grounds please go
ahead Frank thank you renko
what a pleasure to be at this workshop
and this is stock is going to be very
much about the offense
I'm going to talk about an ldp that
doesn't send uh wrote down for
inhomogeneous dense errors main random
grass and I'm going to use that to study
the spectral radius of two matrices
associated with an innomogeneous errors
or any random graph so that is what this
talk is about and there's three parts
I'm first going to
spend time on uh recalling for you what
this ldp for graphones is
uh in an homogeneous setting and then
I'm going to apply it essentially using
the contraction principle but the that
is easy in the uh I'm going to use it
for adjacency Matrix and laplacian
Matrix The adjacency Matrix is easier to
deal with than the laplacian Matrix and
you'll see where some of the problems
come from in The laplacian Matrix case
and we're going to derive an ldp for the
spectral radius of these two matrices
and then are going to go into what the
rate function associated with these two
ldps is and what we are able to to prove
about them what we're not able to prove
about them and this will in the end uh
go and uh and lead to some open problems
and this is Joint work with four people
Arijit chakrabhati for my cycle Qatar
who is enlightened Martin is currently a
PhD student in Cambridge and Matthias
fragar is doing a postdoc in Stockholm
at the moment
so that's the program for this stop and
I'm going to first talk about this ldp
for a homogeneous rainy random graph and
I can immediately skip the first page
because this is just telling you uh what
graphins are and that there's a graph on
there there's a cup metric so I can
immediately
skip that the only symbol I want you to
remember is this Phi which is this
measure preserving bijective map that
you need to to go to the equivalence
classes of gar phones and this has to do
with the you know relabeling of your
vertices and that's the only thing that
that I will need you to remember for for
later and the rest is all standard stuff
that you have a Twitter space and this
cut metric fine now the setting that we
are going to look at is that we're going
to pick
a reference platform
and we want to know a little bit about
this graph one we want that both the
logarithm of this the reference graph
and the logarithm of one of this
reference graph are integral so we do
not need the government to be bounded
away from zero one but when they get
close to zero close to one that they
they have to be sort of integrable in in
a logarithmic sense
and then what we're going to do is you
say this is a key given object
and then you're going to approximate
this grapheme by an N by n block graphem
and you have to do it in such a way that
this will converge in L1 to your
reference graphene this reference
garment is fixed forever
and then what you're going to do is that
once you have this block gruffle which
is a good approximation of your
reference graph or that you've picked uh
at the beginning you're going to
construct an innomogeneous errors really
random graph by saying I have n vertices
and I'm going to connect vertex I with
vertex J with a probability that's given
by RN of I over n j Over N so a Vertex
has a label and then I Over N is a
number between 0 and 1 and you're going
to connect these two vertices with that
probability and this will give you a
dense but in homogeneous uh errors we in
a random graph as and as you let N Go to
Infinity this will start to of course
look more and more like your reference
graph form that you've picked and this
is how you're going to create a sequence
of random graphs that will in some sense
converge to your reference rifle
and you will need that similar
conditions like this also apply to log
RN and log 1 minus RN in order to to be
okay with this condition here
so I have defined now a sequence of
dense
in homogeneous errors when you render
graphs and I want to understand uh what
I can say about this this object
and with this graph you associate an
empirical graphene by simply saying
vertices
I pick an X and A Y and I look at
vertices with labels upper part upper
integer part NX and then why and if
they're connected I put a one and if
they're not connected I put a zero so
this is the empirical graphone which is
an N by n block graphon that I associate
with my random uh erdoswaini random
brush fine and I'm going to use the the
twiddle symbol when I want to talk about
the law of the equivalence class
associated with this empirical graph
form because we need to be working in
this space w Twitter
so this is the the model that I've set
up and now we're going to ask some
questions about it
now uh the the homogeneous uh ldp by
Chatterjee and vardan was generalized by
Dara and Sen to an ldp that says okay if
I look at the this this uh this sequence
of probability measures of the empirical
graphones this satisfies an ldp on our
graphene space of the equivalence
classes and it has a rate and choose two
fairer fair enough of course that's also
the rate that appears the homogeneous
setting and there's a rate function that
you get by
taking the rate function as you see it
in the Chatterjee via theorem except you
are going to now not put a constant here
but you're going to put your reference
graph from here and here is the the
graphome
where the ldp says well what's the
probability that I'm close to that
graphene
and here is just an interval over the
relative entropy with parameters r x y
and h x y and this is your rate function
and then you're supposed to minimize
over all uh all the all the equivalents
uh age that you get and so here's this
Phi of this measurable objective
transformation and that is going to be
your rate function
in the space w twiddle with the Cartoon
Network and so it's a it's a
generalization of the homogeneous case
and there there there are uh the
technical issues involved because you
need to do approximations how General
can you make this reference graph phone
and and stuff like that and uh and in
the end
um this has came up my micro marketing
uh picked up on this paper and there
were a number of things that could be
slightly uh slightly tweaked to to to to
include as general as possible uh ours
but this this is our our warhawks and so
this is the theorem that describes the
large deviation principle of my
inhomogeneous errors or any random graph
in the space of God Falls and that's
well understood and now we're going to
try and do something with this namely
we're going to apply this to to study
the spectral radius of the adjacency
Matrix of My Graph GN and also the
laplacian Matrix
okay now in order
to do that uh I need to quickly remind
you of some very basic stuff given a
graph on there is this linear integral
operator which is which we call a
graphene operator associated with your
graphene H and this has an L2 norm and
uh and that is an object that that we
need
and uh and and this object is is well
behaved and that that has been uh you
know looked at in great detail in in
standard Theory and this is also very
much you know uh uh L2 theory of uh of
operators coming from government Theory
so nothing fancy but this is the norm of
uh of this graphene operator so every
graph form has an operator associated
with it and it has a norm and this
object will be important for us
basic facts are the following any
government you pick this is a
self-adjoined bounded and continuous
operator it has a maximal eigenvalue and
Associate Associated eigenfunctions that
are all strictly positive unless of
course H is equal to zero but we are not
allowing for that
and then there is a maximal and actually
this Norm is also the maximal eigenvalue
of this operator so this is all basic
operator Theory and and we we need this
in order to so do you just interject it
you're not along it so H has to be
strictly positive well no actually uh we
we uh we started with a reference graph
form of which we do want some
interabilities near zero but the
reference graphene will not be able to
hit zero but it can get close to zero
but it has to do so in a certain
integrable manner
that's all
questions okay
so so let's go yeah so does that
condition already imply irreducibility
of the operator
um sorry say that again so the integral
condition that you have does that imply
the operator is irreducible I think it
does okay
[Music]
so we're going to go to the first ldp
and this ldp says let Lambda n be the
the maximum eigenvalue of the adjacency
Matrix for finite and of my graph that I
get by doing this approximation and
let's call P star sorry
um so it's not only that it implies
irreducible ability but for example it
doesn't allow bipartite Graphics right
where you have zero on the Block I mean
I I take a reference graph on this
reference graph from has to satisfy a
certain condition otherwise I cannot do
the other right and it in particular as
a condition that implies it can't be for
example a bipart yeah
correct
okay so uh let's p and star be the law
of the largest eigenvalue of the
adjacency Matrix of the finite graph
that I generate
using the RN which approximates my
reference graph from r
and here's an ldp that is an immediate
consequence of
the darascent theorem and the
contraction principle it says this
largest eigenvalue divided by n will
satisfy an ldp on the real numbers with
rate and choose to and there will be a
rate function that you obtain by just
saying this is the rate function in the
direction ldp and you need to minimize
this over all choices of H twiddle in
your graphing space w title that whose
Norm is equal to Beta
right and then since this hasn't this
was an Infamous overall I uh you can
just say that this now becomes an
infinite over the w space rather than
the W Total Space and the reason is that
this operator Norm is invariant under
you uh applying a a projection to uh to
your your age and therefore we you have
a formula here now it you you this is
really in the space of Graphics you
don't have to worry about the
equivalence classes anymore and you're
supposed to take the the rate function
in in the Dara send ldp and minimize it
under all those for subject to the
condition that the operator Norm of the
graphene H is equal to B beta and it's
essentially easy it follows from the
theorem uh the the phone and the
contraction plus the fact that there are
certain nice continuity properties of
this operator and later when we go to
looking at the largest eigenvalue of the
laplacian Matrix we'll see that there's
some trouble coming up there but here
everything for the adjacency Matrix is
still okay
so we have here do you know what the
optimal age looks like I'm going to say
something about it that's so the we're
now going to say well what are we able
to say about this rate function I'm
going to draw a picture on the next
slide
well
um we're going to need a constant which
is the operator Norm of my reference
graphene
and that number is uh
is important because if you would pick
your beta so this ldp says uh what
happens when this Lambda n Over N is
close to Beta well if that beta is the
operator Norm then actually the solution
is just H being equal to R there's no
large deviation and that's your your
zero
and perhaps I should first show this
picture
um so the ldp says
I'm writing it in in an informal way the
probability that Lambda n Over N is
close to Beta is approximately e to the
minus the n22 that's the rate and here
is my rate function and this rate
function sort of qualitatively looks
like this picture it has a unique zero
at beta being the operator Norm of the
graphene R which is the reference
platform and when you want to pick beta
that and then you're talking about
typical Behavior so that corresponds to
a zero of your rate function and it
means typically Lambda n Over N is going
to be close to that number and this
curve is telling you what uh what this
rate function is when you are away from
that point and and it has this shape and
let me State what we know about this
kernel sorry what we know about this
rate function in a theorem we know we
can prove that it's continuous in that
it's unimodal we can prove that it has a
unique zero at CR so these are the kind
of things that you always expect and
hope to be able to prove we can also
prove that the curve is strictly a
monotone on either side of CR so
strictly decreasing on the left is
strictly increasing on the right and
also in the space of
equivalence classes this variational
formula has
has Solutions and this set is non-empty
and compact in that space so we know
that the solutions are there and they're
compact but in general
it is not easy
to say much about what these minimizes
would be and consequently about what
this curve is so
at this point you say don't actually say
more about this curve is a bit elusive
right okay so that's the story there is
an ldp for the spectral radius of the
adjacency Matrix and we have some
control of what the rate function looks
like
and the fact that it's it's bounded at
zero is related to the integrability of
log of R exactly the fact that it's
bounded absolutely exactly it's only a
problem yeah and and the other values
are simply not possible
okay now can we say something more about
what uh the rate function actually is
well and how uh what the minimizer is uh
in in some sub cases and we looked at
the case where the reference bar form is
rank one
and of course this is a celebrated
choice and we're going to make life a
little easier for ourselves and say okay
let this new now actually be bounded
away from zero and one in order not to
get into uh further details
yes we can say a lot and all that we
know need to know is we need to know the
first four moments of this uh function
that is a function from zero one to zero
one of course it has to be measurable
and
it's in the rank one case it's a little
exercise to show that this Norm of uh
the uh the operator associated with the
reference graph is just the second
moment
and there is a further number that plays
a role in what I'm going to say in a
second and that is this particular uh uh
interval I'm sorry this should have been
with respect to New York there's
something missing a new Dr I'm sorry
about that and so this will be the
difference between the square of the
third moment of new and the square of
the fourth moment of new this is a
positive number because this Nu is
between uh zero and one
and so there are numbers in terms of the
first three moments four moments of of
the new function
and the the the fear of making a more
precise statement right yeah what do you
mean by rank one operator is like a rank
one operator said my reference graph
form is a product
that's that's here right and for some
new but it also means that it's a rank
one operator yeah yeah it has one
non-zero eigenvalue and all the other
ones are zero right
and in terms of this function you have
four moments and then the answer is that
if you are looking at near the zero you
will see the usual quadratic behavior
and and the the constant is computable
in terms of these uh three moments
and
we have also information coming back to
your question Remco any uh H that is a
minimizer
is up to this equivalence uh
given by it's very close to ARF of
course because you're very close to the
minimum and and if you're at CR then
your minimizer is r
it is a perturbation of R and the
perturbation is linear in the distance
between beta minus CR so we're close to
uh CR with beta either on the left or on
the right and there's a certain shape uh
with which you will perturb
this uh your your
um your rank one uh reference graphum
and so there's a precise description of
what your Graph Room will look like
um any minimizer will look like if you
are close to uh to the minimum
yum
do you expect that for beta close to CR
there'll be a unique minimizer
uh we certainly know that to to linear
order this is the unique shape right but
but there could be harder order
perturbations where things are not
unique but certainly to to to Leading
order in the approximation the
perturbation is unique yeah
you didn't like it
so still amazes the question whether you
would I mean you may not be able to
prove it mathematically but would you
expect it to be unique or not I don't
know
I I have no idea no idea it it might be
I would expect it to be unique but I
don't know how to prove that
so if I am looking at from a graph
Theory point of view so what is the
entropy minimizing graph and how does it
look like it looks like so if if apart
from the equivalence class class it says
it looks like R plus beta minus CR times
this object and and this object depends
on your reference graphene and apart
from the equivalence classes that's the
solution
but is there interpretation like in
terms of clicks or something that comes
up in Triangle counts no no because this
this my my reference coffin is assumed
to be positive everywhere it's in fact
rank one and more and then this this uh
this is never going to sort of
accumulate or anything or have
singularities I don't see that so so
this is the this is the formula
so in particular it's polynomial in R
would you believe that to be true beyond
the rank one setting no I would not
believe that to be two I'm going to make
some remarks about that's very
interesting and good uh good questions
um now uh first of all uh it it remains
open whether my rate function is convex
in many cases rate functions are convex
in many cases they're not
we have no idea how to prove that here
it dependence on beta is complicated
we do not April or expect that this
function would be analytic function in
beta because there could easily be
bifurcations occurring as I vary beta in
in the solution you know maybe yes maybe
no we just don't know and and it's it's
naive to expect that this would not
happen I mean if you if you uh if you
remember the pictures that Charles put
up on Monday in this Ed strangle model
okay it's a different story but but then
then you know things can be very
complicated and what should not a
primary sort of say oh this will be okay
but
we don't know
now
the scaling Corrections are not rank one
so even though you start with a rank one
Matrix this is not rank one
so uh the moment you move away
from your minimum you lose already
immediately the rank one property
and this curvature that we found here
so how does your rate function behave on
the behavior quadratically with a
certain curvature and that fits nicely
with the CLT that
that was proved
around about the same time uh for the uh
for this
spectral radius of the
um of the largest eigenvalue and so the
fact that the variance and this thing
match up that's part of the folklore of
large deviation Theory large deviation
Theory does not apply the central limit
theorem so it's not for free but very
often these things match up and in this
case things are also matching up so so
life is halfway decent at at uh at the
minimum sometimes you can also conclude
the central limit theorem from the
Lord's Aviation principle double
derivative yeah yeah but you need to do
more and you actually need to to go a
little bit in the complex plane so
whereas the law of large numbers is
immediate from ldp clts are not you need
a little extra work but very often they
fit but we will see further for the uh
for the laplaccia Matrix no something
else is happening
now
so this sort of concludes the story for
the spectral radius of the adjacency
Matrix yeah you can go beyond rank one
you can go to finite rank there's
there's still things you can do but the
story does remain that uh it's not easy
to get detailed properties of what this
rate function really uh what what its
properties are as a function of beta so
um I was wondering what if instead you
would allow a simple sort of rank one
analog for bipartite graphene and then
looked instead of the largest eigenvalue
at the smallest which would be sort of a
nice analogues yeah
what these techniques can be generalized
to that
[Music]
um
maybe I
I would need to think about that but
that's certainly uh an interesting uh
question I mean they're they're there is
a lot of flexibility in what we're doing
but there are also some some hurdles
that and so I I
perhaps but it certainly certainly good
idea but I I would not sort of
immediately bet on this and say I I I
know how to do this by tomorrow morning
no
even more difficult would be the
directed case yes yes because then your
operator is no longer self-joined that's
a disaster that's a disaster
okay so
in the remaining time I'm going to focus
on what happens when we do not look at
the adjacency Matrix but at the
laplacian Matrix and the laplacia Matrix
is that you take a diagonal matrix which
is the whose elements are the degrees of
the vertices and you subtract the
adjacency Matrix from it and this object
is sort of interesting when you want to
start to run a random walk on your graph
GN because then the spectrum of this
operator is going to tell you something
about mixing times but we are going to
look at this as just an operator in
itself and say well what about the
largest eigenvalue of this operator and
can we derive an ldp for this and that's
what uh the the second uh ldp that I'm
going to tell you about will will be
and it turns out that this laplacian uh
Matrix poses new challenges because it
is in in many respects uh a somewhat
more delicate object than the adjacency
Matrix uh and that's partly because this
operator even though it's very simple uh
is is not sort of living and how shall I
put it it's not sort of quite living in
the same world as the an does and in
fact what we're going to see is that
there is now going to be a difference
between deviations upwards and downwards
because they're going to live on
different scales they have different
costs which is not what was happening
for the adjacency Matrix because the
cost was always n choose two
and no matter where you were moving up
or whether you were moving down and so
now there's going to be uh two ldps one
on the right and one on the left and I
want to tell you about those and the
laplacian operator lacks certain
continuity properties that make make
this uh this analysis more difficult
I have put here in progress because
there are there are still you know
two small technical things that were
sort of worrying about that have to deal
with this and so it's it's not uh
completely done yet there is some
struggle here going on which I I will
not go into the technical details of
that but here is what
we are having
again to formulate things I need to talk
about graphene operators uh there is a
degree function that says you pick an X
and you just integrate your graph an
over y then that will correspond to the
degree associated in the limit with the
point x there's a degree operator
associated with that which is very
simple because this is a multiplication
operator and then the LaPlace the
laplacian operator would be the operator
that I had before it's so so this is is
going to be my degree operator because
if I integrate out over Y and this u x
doesn't depend on why I get D X Y so I
just get the this beginning part is that
operator and the other one is the old
operator that I had which was the uh the
operator associated with my Gotham so
I'm dealing now with a different
operator which is a difference of two
operators the degree operator and the
operator that I had before the Gotham
operator
and this operator is not as well behaved
because for instance if you have a
sequence of Graphics that converges to
limiting the iPhone
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of
the this is the Prussian operator at
that sequence may not converge to the
limit so there's a lack of continuity
properties here that we did not have
for the adjacency Matrix okay
let me again introduce the L2 Norm of
this object
and let's see what uh what we are able
to show well this is certainly a bounded
operator we know that it's lower
semicontinuous in h it's not continuous
in fact if you look at star graphs then
you're going to see that you're you're
going to have discontinuities there
and I'm going to introduce a number
which is the Norm of that more
complicated operator now the laplacian
operator and we're going to call the C
hat R and the C hat R plays the complete
analog role of the CR that we had before
which was the norm of of the graphene
operator
and this should be the zero of a rate
function and in fact we have a downward
ldp so we're going to look at what is
the maximal eigenvalue of this laplacian
operator divided by n it has a low p n
star and it turns out that there is a
downward ldp with weight and choose two
and with the rate function that is uh of
the type we had before you take the
infimum of the Dara send rate function
and you normalize you you put as a
constraint that the LaPlace operator of
that H is less than or equal to Beta and
the downward ldp is the statement that
this it's it's it says the probability
that your largest eigenvalue for your
laplacian Matrix divided by n is less
than or equal to Beta is going to decay
uh with a certain rate function and
since we're looking at the downward rate
function it is uh we're talking about a
a function here that looks at the left
piece and it says if you want to be
below something that is below this
number you're going to pay some cost and
the function looks looks like like that
and again we are able to prove some very
general properties about this rate
function and we're also able to show
that there again there is a uh the the
the minimizer of that
variation of formula defining your rate
function is non-empty and it is compact
in in the W Total Space
and so all is good
um and we have uh we we have found a
picture on the left so if you say if you
are uh largest eigenvalue of La Plata
major this wants to be small smaller
than what its typical value would be you
pay on the scale and choose two
and okay now we're able to say a bit
more uh about what is happening near the
zero if we're assuming that the
reference graph one is positive definite
which is more General than rank one
then uh we're able to say more and what
we do is we're we're going to introduce
a kind of tilt
of my reference graph phone think of
this as a kind of brother of the Khmer
transformation as you do it a little bit
like that but now in the world of
garfons and you're going to tilt it by a
function that depends on X and you have
to choose this tilt this tilt plays the
role of a LaGrange multiplier such that
the function the Tilted function
achieves the minimum beta so I'm sort of
tilting my graphene my reference graph
and such that the the deviation of of
beta now becomes the typical value for
this tilted reference Carphone so that's
very much in the spirit of how you prove
Commerce theorem
and is this data unique
Theta is unique yeah yeah because you
can uh
it is yeah
and then in that case you you can uh
find out what the zero of your rate
function is it's just uh the uh the
Supreme Norm of your uh of your degree
function and what we find is that we
have a more simple representation for
the rate function and it is an infimum
over a certain set where the degree has
to become has to be larger than the beta
so there's a certain representation in
terms of uh of the the function that are
introduced you have to integrate it over
a certain set
and if you see what my rate function is
doing as it approaches it's zero but
it's approaching it now from the left
because I'm only having a downward ldp
there is a quadratic term but there is a
term that depends on what the degree
function is doing near its maximum and
this is going to vanish
as beta goes to C hat so you're not
going to get quadratic Behavior you're
going to get behavior that is below
quadratic
and the way it is below quadratic
depends very much on what the degree
function is associated with your
reference waffle and how it is sort of
Behaving near its maximal value and
there are various scenarios possible but
the main messages you go to zero faster
than quadratic so it's not standard CLT
[Music]
for this measure of Sr beta to be zero
do you need they still need the fact
that R is positive definite or just the
fact that this is zero does not need not
yeah for for the theorem you needed it's
positive definite and to to get this
representation and then you note uh
afterwards uh that yeah well the the the
positive definiteness will also give you
this bound right I I I do need it
everywhere
okay I'm moving uh two more slides to go
um there's also an upward ldp the upward
ldp has a rate function that you can
again write down
and this upward ldp however lives at
rate n not n ratio choose two so it is
cheaper to make upward large deviation
than it is to make downward large
deviations and the rate function is
quadratic and there there's some
constant here which we we
think we know but we haven't really
proved that yet so I'm being more rough
here because we haven't really proved
so this picture looks
like the other picture at the other side
except the rate is now n and not n
choose two so deviations in the upward
direction for the laplacian Matrix are
cheaper than downward larger deviations
and for the adjacency Matrix it was the
same on both sides
and are you basically changing one row
and column something like that infect
you it turns out that that somehow in
the whole story here the the the maximum
degree the large deviation of the
maximum degree is somehow dominating the
story
and so I'm coming uh this is my last
slide uh so there is an upward and a
downward ldp they have different rates
uh to get your hands on the on what
these rate functions are exactly doing
as a function of beta remains a bit
elusive we have obtained some properties
of them and uh and uh again uh are they
convex we don't know should we expect
them to be analytic I I doubt it but
these questions remain open uh it also
remains open when you want to go beyond
the positive definite case because then
Things become a bit more tricky with
this laplacian operator
and thirdly there is no Central limit
theorem known for uh this object and
that probably is related to the fact
that we have different rate functions on
the left and on the right and and on the
left things are less than quadratic on
the right they are quadratic uh and so
there's an asymmetry here and that must
mean that if you are trying to get
something Central limit theorem like
uh for this object it's going to be a
more difficult story it simply has not
been done and we don't know what to do
it might not be true and it might not be
true so but that's an enigmatic question
so the rest is all up in the clouds
Christian's question is very relevant
and you could of course say well what
about the second largest eigenvalue I
mean the sky is the limit thank you very
much
[Applause]
foreign
any further questions yes
so I guess Frank so I guess uh one maybe
the more substantial question is um you
know in the sparse regime yeah so in the
smartest regime if you look at the
empirical spectral distribution it's
sort of known because of this beautiful
work of uh Charles bordanev and sales
that it depends on the local properties
of the graph like local weak convergence
yeah and then there are these so then
you can ask what about large deviations
for the empirical spectral distribution
and then now there's like this uh you
know cool work of like border and Caputo
about like local large deviations for
local uh big converter so do you think
some of this stuff can be extended to
the sports regime not the maximal
eigenvalue but like I I don't think it
can be extended because you you really
need different
uh tools I I say what we've done here
you're all building it on on graphene
Theory so I don't know that of course
there there's this intermediate regime
interpolating all the way between sparse
and and dense where at the level of the
spectral distribution we we know a lot
and you you get interesting things that
have to do with uh uh you know
being a semi-circle laws but for the
largest eigenvalue uh this is not clear
and I I think it will really require
these these these other techniques to to
make uh I I don't think that this uh has
much to say about that problem right I
guess not the maximal but like if you
look at the empirical structural
distribution then then it may be because
that's a much easier object for instance
we know how where that scales do in in
the whole range between sparse and uh
and dense and then large deviations
would be an interesting thing to do I I
I
you know but that that's a calculation
also
um yeah you get into all this uh Quantum
you know free probability combinatorics
and stuff like that so so I I don't know
the answer but that's certainly uh an
interesting thing to look at okay and
yeah one minor question I mean uh
suppose you look at an exponential
random graph model which you know we
know converted to some sort of graph
funds and very appropriate spaces uh
appropriate conditions and then you ask
now you want to condition an exponential
random graph model to have a weird you
know whatever spectral property can your
techniques extend there there I think
one one should be able to to do to do
something I mean if you would be tilting
by your largest eigenvalue then this
this is going to certainly in the dense
case is going to help you sure
thank you
um I wonder like I at some point I see
you mentioned the um cut magic for the
laplacian that generated from the gravel
um so I wonder how that is defined and
I'm curious on the diagonal parts that
how that net would come into the
definition of the cognitive I mean I
mean the the cryptomatic and the space
is what it is we're not we're not
changing anything I'm just saying that
the LaPlace operator is lacking certain
continuity properties that your
adjacency Matrix operator had and those
things are are hitting you and they're
hitting you because most of your
calculations you do in the space w
rather than W Twitter
and uh and and so certain continuity
properties make the proof harder
and that that's all what I mean the
space is what it is
what it was before okay I'm not changing
that I'm just saying that the operator
is is is less well-behaved and that's
something we we really need to struggle
with
thank you
so it's well known from spec to graph
series that
instead of looking at the laplacian
looking at the normalized laplacian
where you multiply with the square root
of L is nicer behaved it's nearer to the
trigger constant and things like that so
what do you expect it's a normalized
laplacian has a two-sided ldp Maybe
maybe I mean that that makes life easier
we we actually haven't done that we
haven't really thought about that uh but
uh yeah that
that would be nice to look at and and
and and possibly this makes
some of our trouble disappear so it
would be good to to consider that
because I I I'm not I mean we haven't
done that yet
it's not a good suggestion
a final question
foreign
so out of curiosity your notion of
relative entropy here yeah the point
wise average
do you know whether that has reasonable
Duality like John scavara done
representation where you may be super
sub graphs or something like that
yeah but I don't see what what that dual
representation would do for us here of
course you can write relative entropy uh
as uh again in a kind of variational
form but I I I I I haven't we haven't
been able to to use that we were just
Computing head-on with this expression
and putting a variational thing in
between is only going to make life
harder I think
but I don't know whether it might be
useful at some point
all right I propose that we thank you
[Applause]
and it's my pleasure to introduce Kavita
ramananda who's the second